In retrospect, some would say, October 23rd,
1985 was the day the Chinese Communist Party
died.
By the mid-80s, virtually every inch of the
country had been transformed by well over
a decade of radical economic reform.
But after that day in October, when Deng Xiaoping
explicitly described state policy, as quote,
“Let[ting] some people get rich first”,
the proverbial cat was undeniably and seemingly
irreversibly out of the bag.
It didn’t matter what ‘-ism’ defined
its economy, or, in the words of Deng, what
color the cat was, only that it was effective
at catching mice, for ideology had no place
in this new China.
Class struggle and collectivization had already
given way to new inequalities.
But with Deng’s unequivocal proclamations,
gone too was even the façade.
There was nothing especially subtle about
it.
Any American visitor to China in the roughly
thirty years after 1980 — myself included
— inevitably returns with the same surprised
observation: “China looks more Capitalist
than America”, (and that’s saying something!).
Most iconically, there are the McDonald’s.
So, so many McDonald’s.
And you can’t miss the KFCs.
Twice as many, in fact, as in America.
Street vendors everywhere trying to make a
buck.
Shopping malls, Apple Stores, and designer
handbags.
Chinese consumerism is globally unmatched
in its ostentatiousness.
But the culture of Capitalism has seeped much
deeper than mere brand names.
The American obsession with buying houses
launched the greatest financial crisis of
the 21st century… yet is thoroughly put
to shame by the Chinese, who ‘collect’
third and even fourth homes — all empty,
bought before completion, and likely to never
be lived in by anyone — like the rest of
the world collects stamps.
Then there are the class distinctions.
Americans are no strangers to economic inequality.
But, at least in theory, no law stops you
from packing up and moving to Beverly Hills.
In China, your place of birth quite literally
determines your place in the world.
Household registration — or hukou — means
you can move from middle-of-nowhere Gansu
province to cosmopolitan Shanghai — but
its public schools, hospitals, and jobs will
forever be legally off-limits.
Place of birth matters everywhere, but only
in China do authorities not even pretend otherwise.
And if all that doesn’t convince you “Socialism
with Chinese characteristics” is but a euphemism
for “state Capitalism” there’s plenty
more evidence to choose from…
Starting in 1980, international corporations
could buy advertising space in the Communist
Party’s official magazine — albeit with
one exception: Coca-Cola was explicitly banned.
In the two years between 1986 and 88, student
support for “Communism” fell from 38%
to just 6.1.
And bear in mind, these are officially-sanctioned
surveys!
Deng Xiaoping even warned that although China
should “maintain vigilance” against the
“Right”, it should be “primarily”
wary of the “Left”.
Since the death of Mao, the Communist Party
has maintained only the thinnest veneer of
tradition in the interest of continuity — acting
out the motions of increasingly-vague 5-year
plans and increasingly-predictable Politburo
procedure.
But while the rest of the world has largely
played along with this political theater,
we’ve all long since realized: underneath
this nearly transparent Maoist packaging is
pure, raw, Big Mac-loving, unadulterated Capitalism
in all but name.
Then, Xi Jinping happened.
Today, after a decade of this new era, you
wouldn’t just have to be an optimist to
not see how things have changed, you’d truly
have to be living under a rock.
And to notice the similarities between Mao
and Xi is to be confronted with an uncomfortable
question: Did this Maoist revival emerge spontaneously,
implausibly manufactured by one man alone?
Or, did even the most clear-eyed China-watchers
fundamentally misunderstand the past five
decades?
One way or another, a reappraisal is overdue.
Sponsored by CuriosityStream and Nebula.
Get both for just $15/year and watch my latest
Nebula-exclusive Original debunking the myth
that China “lifted 800 million people out
of poverty”.
Despite being one of the most common myths
about China, I’ve been unable to cover it
for fear of demonetization — until now,
thanks to Nebula.
Sign up and get access to all five of these
exclusive Original episodes and much more.
On the 9th of September 1976, China experienced
the most traumatic and destabilizing thing
that can happen to a cult of personality — the
death of that personality.
With the sole exception, perhaps, of North
Korea’s Kim Il-Sung, no country has ever
had so many of its political eggs in one basket.
China was the Communist Party.
And the Communist Party was Mao.
His complete monopoly on power created a volatile
vacuum of power and all but guaranteed a succession
crisis after his fatal heart attack.
How you interpret what happened next is where
history diverges.
In one version — the one most of us have
come to believe — the death of Mao forced
the Party — indeed, the entire country — to
do some serious soul searching.
His absence gave Deng’s generation room
to critically re-examine the horrors of the
past quarter century and steer the country
in a new direction.
There’s simply no denying that the scale
and speed of China’s modernization was a
direct result of these reforms.
Had Mao’s 4 confidants not been purged a
mere month after his death, the word “TikTok”
would probably still mean an early-2000s pop
song.
You wouldn’t know what “Shenzhen” is
today.
In a very different version of history, Deng
Xiaoping’s greatest innovation is not liberalizing
the Chinese economy, exactly, but knowing
the secret passwords to join the globalized,
American-led export market.
In this world, China’s post-Mao leaders
realize there’s a practical limit to the
amount of starvation the average person is
willing to endure in the name of peasant revolution.
They realize, after ‘89, that photographs
of tanks do a lot of damage to the national
brand, and firing squads are bad for business.
At home, China maintains the prominence of
Mao and continues speaking the language of
Socialism.
But abroad, it emphasizes the “…with Chinese
characteristics” part.
It’s a ruse the rest of the world is either
too naive to notice or too blinded by dollar
signs to act on.
The truth, it would seem, is an uneasy mix
of both.
Though, probably more of the latter.
On one hand, Mao’s death did allow for the
entry of a new — previously mythical — ‘m’-word
to the government’s vocabulary — ‘mistake’.
Accompanying it were ‘democracy’, ‘opposition’,
and even, if you can believe it, ‘human
rights’ — though its precise definition
may have been, shall we say, lost in translation.
Yet, no sooner had Deng uttered these words,
when old red lines were redrawn.
In other words, the scope of permissible speech
widened by a remarkable degree in a remarkably
short period of time.
But Deng’s “four cardinal principles”
still left a lot to be desired.
In the party’s own words, Mao’s “contributions
to the Chinese revolution far outweigh his
mistakes…”
Another important thing to note — something
we may have dismissed as a mere ‘historical
detail’ for the fifty years between then
and now but today in 2022 is clearly anything
but — is the fact that Mao’s death led
to the very first policy ‘debates’ in
the PRC.
For the first time in the country’s history,
you could say things like “Hmm, maybe Mao
was only 70% correct”.
That’s a pretty big deal!
Much bigger than it sounds.
That 30% tolerance could be the difference
between, say, China being comfortable importing
foreign-made mRNA vaccines and sealing its
borders shut for years to come.
Anyway, history remembers the victor, and
Deng’s Reformist camp was decisively victorious.
But that makes it all too easy to forget that
there were other factions.
The more Maoist “Leftist” coalition slowly
faded from the spotlight, but, in hindsight,
never quite disappeared.
Leftists couldn’t exactly speak their minds
freely, yet still enjoyed some protection
under the banner of the unassailable “Great
Chairman”.
Censorship is always a cat-and-mouse game
and the more aggressive the cat, the more
clever become the mice.
Political groups in China quickly learned
they could get away with just a little bit
more while waving a Little Red Book.
Ultimately, Leftists were at the mercy of
the Reformist-led Communist Party, who reluctantly
tolerated their existence, if only as a counterbalance
to the right.
But what Deng couldn’t have predicted was
that several Earth-shattering global crises
many years later would unexpectedly tip the
balance, once again, in the Leftists’ favor
— allowing them to re-emerge from the shadows.
However profoundly the fall of the Soviet
Union may have affected the world, it hit
especially close to home in China.
The two countries had long since splintered
ideologically but they still had more in common
than not.
With the Russians out of the picture and no
other large, industrialized role models to
be found, China was effectively left to carry
the mantle of Socialism alone.
This was uncharted territory and the stakes,
clearly, were existential.
But what, exactly, was the lesson for Chinese
leaders?
While Deng’s Reformers ‘learned’ that
the Soviets had liberalized too slowly, Leftists
took away the opposite conclusion — that
reform was the problem.
Whatever disagreements lingered, they were
thoroughly put to rest after 2008.
Just as the Soviet collapse triggered anxious
introspection and delivered a political win
for the Leftist coalition, so too did the
Global Financial Crisis reverberate in China.
While Americans were preoccupied with real
estate and the rest of the world, with its
second, third, and fourth-order effects, China
buckled down for a storm, pumping an unfathomable
amount of credit into its economy in anticipation
of hard times to come.
Shiny airports!
Roads.
Roads to the middle of nowhere.
Roads connecting two middle-of-nowheres.
And yes, the colossal High-Speed Rail network
the rest of the world marvels at.
But the looming storm never arrived.
Even though many of these roads proved useless
and high-speed trains to the desert sat predictably
empty, when the expected alternative was mass
unemployment, it felt a lot like a victory.
Not only did China emerge from the global
financial crisis unscathed, but it did so
as the only major economy to actually grow.
And by double digits, no less.
In just a few short months, Chinese leaders
both lost their reverence for U.S. economic
policy — arguably, U.S. policy period — and
gained immense self-confidence in their own
system.
…Or rather, re-gained.
The last time China stood this tall was under
Mao.
The 2008 Beijing Olympics didn’t hurt, either.
Meanwhile, around that same time, the son
of a powerful revolutionary named Bo Xilai
rises to national fame precisely by tapping
into this Maoist nostalgia.
Bo was not a normal Chinese bureaucrat.
He was charismatic.
He liked the spotlight.
And, most importantly, he was not boring.
This highly unusual personal approach to politics
both made him extremely well-liked and probably
led to his ultimate demise.
In short, Bo Xilai was described as a “mini-Mao”,
and his policies as ushering in “Chinese
Socialism 3.0”.
He built affordable housing, saved struggling
State Enterprises, and helped level the playing
field for poor migrants.
Above all, he proved that Socialism, at least
one particular flavor, still had cachet in
China.
Not unlike Bernie Sanders or Donald Trump,
his popularity exposed a long-dormant political
segment.
Now, nothing changed overnight.
New McDonald’s were still being built.
The iPhone was only beginning to achieve velocity
— largely built with Chinese manufacturing
and bought by the Chinese middle-class.
But, if you were looking closely, the stage
had been set.
The Chinese Leftist movement was making a
comeback.
When Xi Jinping inherited power in 2012, he
was reportedly shocked to discover CIA spies
working at the highest levels of the Party.
That, of course, was concerning on its own.
But even more concerning was what that meant.
After three decades of market reform, China
had become near-fatally Capitalist.
We’re not talking about D.C. lobbyist Crony
Capitalism here.
There was a second-hand market for Cadre positions.
Let that sink in: you could buy your way into
the Communist party, albeit under the table.
That was how the CIA allegedly infiltrated
the party.
They simply paid.
And if cadres were willing to sell out their
country that easily, it goes without saying:
the only chairman these corrupt officials
were loyal to was the Mao staring back at
them on banknotes.
Xi was horrified to find China occupied by
Capitalists.
As we saw in this earlier video, public-private
collusion enabled breakneck economic growth.
It turns out, the right kind of corruption
can actually speed up development.
But we see now that it also threatened such
necessities to the survival of the Communist
Party as its chain of command.
Xi realized this and launched a multi-year
anti-corruption campaign that took down not
hundreds or thousands but millions of bureaucrats
across China.
In fact, it never really ended.
Many on the outside interpreted this campaign
through the lens of a dictator accumulating
power.
Corruption, after all, is a common pretext
for eliminating one’s rivals.
But this misses the forest for the trees.
Of course Xi Jinping took out some competitors
along the way.
But it’s doubtful he identified a million
and a half competitors.
And of course he’s trying to consolidate
power.
But to what end?
A closer look at history reveals that many
of Xi’s signature campaigns began under
his predecessor, Hu Jintao.
Although the ship was turning too slowly for
many to notice, the new course had long been
set.
As any Socialist will tell you, Capitalism
becomes entrenched.
The ‘vanguard’ of the proletariat — cadres
— tend to… lose sight of their comrades
once they own a BMW.
The difference between Hu and Xi is not so
much ideology but that only the latter has
the political power to overcome this obstacle.
Xi Jinping didn’t instigate the Socialist
revival, but he was the first to make it practically
possible.
And he doesn’t have much time.
The usual explanation for the Communist Party’s
continued existence amidst a sea of Capitalism
is “performance legitimacy”, or the implicit
agreement.
“We’ll make you rich”, it goes, “and
you won’t challenge our authority”.
But perhaps this theory says more about us
than it does about China.
If you’re really looking, there’s a mountain
of evidence suggesting sincere ideology was
there all along.
It’s obvious, in retrospect, that reform
had a lifespan.
Economic growth can’t go on indefinitely.
Even in a country of 1.4 billion, you can
only build so many high-speed trains.
This places the Party on tenuous ground because
its legitimacy would be at the whim of volatile
stock markets and real estate bubbles.
But even if growth did continue, the Communist
Party’s unique claim to power would weaken
with each passing year.
While China was “getting rich”, lots of
other countries were getting rich too.
Reform-era China didn’t have a compelling
source of national pride.
Listen closely and China’s own leaders have
made clear that “making people rich” was
never its complete strategy.
This emphasis on economic growth was always
a temporary and partial measure.
Even Reformers believed in some version of
Socialism.
They just disagreed on how best to get there.
Although it’s ruled by a Communist Party,
it does not claim to be a Communist State.
Communism, after all, is a Utopian destination
that even its most ardent supporters don’t
believe is on the horizon anytime soon.
This is the fundamental source of confusion.
Outsiders, even, or especially, experts not
familiar with Chinese history, see a country
replete with markets and privately-owned c
ompanies.
They see, as we did, that even Communist Party
ranks can be bought for cash and conclude
that “Socialism” is obviously a façade
— a misunderstanding which, ironically,
has suited China quite well.
But look even closer and it’s clear that
this is itself a façade.
Deng Xiaoping said this explicitly — the
state could never truly distance itself from
Mao because he was inseparable from the Party.
The writing has been on the wall, if only
we were looking, since 1980 — just 3 years
after Mao’s death.
The party was only ever going to deviate from
its origins so much.
And remember, that was the best case, coming
from Mr. Reform and Opening himself.
Now, there’s some truth to the “implicit
agreement”.
You can easily see how the proletariat would
be more or less patient on the path to Utopia
depending on how many Big Macs they can afford.
But while reform could have been much longer,
shorter, stricter, or looser, depending on
which coalition won, the existence of the
Communist Party requires that it eventually
justify its monopoly on power.
Otherwise, anyone could rule China.
The other common justification for the party
is the argument that, despite its “flaws”,
it did “lift” 800 million people out of
poverty.
It’s the retort that any critique of China
is met with.
But there’s just one problem: it’s not
really true.
I’ve wanted to debunk this myth for years
but the only way to do so honestly is with
a rather grim and gruesome inspection of Chinese
history, which demonetization makes impossible
on YouTube.
Thanks to Nebula, I was finally able to make
this video, which is now my fifth full-length
Nebula-exclusive Original video.
The amazing thing is that, by signing up for
the CuriosityStream and Nebula bundle, you
can watch all five of these exclusive videos,
plus all these normal video’s sponsor-free,
and other great Nebula Originals for just
$15 bucks a year.
In other words, you can start getting 50%
more PolyMatter for just $15 bucks a year
by signing up to CuriosityStream and Nebula.
On CuriosityStream you’ll find great feature-length
documentaries, like this closer look at one
of history’s most notoriously evil men.
Click the link on screen right now to get
both Nebula and CuriosityStream for fifteen
bucks a year and go watch my Original series
over on Nebula.